Jeanne and been returned home after a
confrontation between gene and the woman
whose baby they were set to adopt
causing the woman to go into early labor
it is new receive and they had just
watched a woman give birth to a baby
that won't be theirs and neither is in
the mood to celebrate
interior Jean and Ben's apartment living
room
later that night an exhausted Jean and
Ben arrived home Jean slumps in the
nearest chair Ben pours a drink holds
out the bottle to Jean she nods he pours
her at last - should we call the
adoption agency she throws him and are
you serious look I just think if they
hear from her first then they do they
sit in silence until we should talk
about our other options Jean looks at at
McCann Ben relents he looks at his watch
it's almost midnight he moves across the
lounge he turns on the television the
New Year's Eve coverage is in full swing
the chair of an excited crowd in the
background can you turn that off what
can you turn that off please
he mutes it tosses the remote they sit
in silence then what did David one gene
gives him an empty look David you saw
him did it he was half an hour I saw the
new gallery so that's well that's why he
wanted to see you on New Year's Eve to
show you a new gallery no so what he
wanted to offer me a retrospective his
eyes widened he goes to speak but I said
I wouldn't do it why because we're
staying home with the baby for 12 months
that's what we agreed and that's what I
told him so why haven't you called him
yet because you should call him tell him
things have changed your fries a [ __ ]
bird now drops his drink so that it
rattles on the table she looks at him so
that's what this is about don't do that
don't don't act like you know what I'm
thinking you're angry you blame no I
don't know you do I don't I know it
wasn't your fault I know that okay
but was it your choice good choice I'm
47 years old women my age can have
babies that's not what I meant I get it
you ran out of eggs chicken I'm you're
not a [ __ ] chicken I'm just saying if
if we had a baby 15 years ago yeah yeah
gene if we had a baby 15 years ago maybe
a lot of things would have been
different
like what what would have been different
it would have been something that that
that we could have done together
something that was about you and me
we agreed we were gonna have a baby when
we were both ready
I was ready you were nothing but ready
you never pushed yourself to get to get
something for yourself I tried I I
pushed you your father pushed you but
you you're your what what am i oh you
were born into our [ __ ] royalty
Radnich you climbed up from the gutter
right well congratulations you're the
[ __ ] poster child for suffering
you're wearing Givenchy for [ __ ] sake
fine she starts undoing the buzz oh wow
[ __ ] is Yvonne she she throws the blouse
on the floor for a second these two
stand facing each other Jean half
undressed then the sound of fireworks
start from outside their window the
colored lights illuminate their faces we
hear muffled cheers from neighboring
apartments Ben steps towards her but she
turns and makes for the nearest room
Jane she closes herself in interior Jean
and Ben's apartment baby's room same
time it's exquisite fully furnished and
delicately decorated baby's bedroom she
takes a deep breath leaning against the
door of a baby's room that will have no
baby Ben on the other side of the door
defeated Jane she doesn't answer both
silent on either side of the closed door
then we see the thought crosses face
settling uneasy like the crazy idea that
it is he presses his head against the
wood whispers I have something I need to
tell you it was a mistake a few months
ago at the Warhol party just once a
waitress and more silence his words so
far gone that they can't be taken back
his eyes are still closed so he doesn't
even notice that she's opened the door
and is standing in front of him what are
you doing I don't know I'm sorry
I'm only telling you boys why are you
telling me this now oh she's pregnant
okay she's not gonna keep it and and I
thought I mean what if you and I don't
don't you [ __ ] dare say another word